welcome to this episode of click to
deploy a series where we show you how
easy it is to deploy solutions from the
google cloud marketplace
in this episode we'll be reviewing how
to set up a redis instance via the cloud
marketplace
in case you're unfamiliar redis is an
in-memory data structure store used as a
database cache and message broker
let's start by searching for redis in
the marketplace
you'll see that we have a few different
deployment options from virtual machines
container images two kubernetes apps
each deployment may be deployed with
different operating systems security
patches or server shapes
for this demo we'll choose the redis
enterprise cloud option
redis enterprise cloud delivers fully
managed redis enterprise as a service
it offers all the capabilities of redis
enterprise while taking care of the
operational aspects associated with
operating redis in the most efficient
manner on google cloud platform
the landing page will display
information about the pricing
documentation
and support
the pricing information displays a high
level estimate of charges
pricing for the solution is based on
hourly consumption of redis enterprise
shards
let's click the subscribe button to
launch the solution
start by choosing a billing account and
agreeing to the terms below which are
the terms about subscription fee billed
monthly and canceling the service
you'll also notice pricing calculator
which can help you see estimated costs
based on factors like time frame shard
hours and data transfer costs
[Music]
we'll choose manage on provider
from here you create a redis
subscription
choose google cloud platform as your
vendor
choose a name
for this video we'll choose testdb
now choose a db size
for this video i'll choose one gigabyte
and 25 000 throughputs per second
[Music]
as you can see our database has been
created and connected to google cloud
now let's test the database
we'll run this python script to see if
the database is working
please note for the purpose of this demo
we use the external db endpoint but we
recommend that in production customers
are using internal db endpoints within
their vpc peering connection for
security and performance reasons
there you have it a redis instance of
the click of a
button if you enjoyed this video please
subscribe and hit the like button below
we encourage you to check out the gcp
marketplace and deploy the solution on
your own thanks for watching
[Music]
you